>>> IN UKRAINE, THE DEATH TOLL
IS RISING NOW IN WHAT HAS BEME
ONE OF THE DEADLIEST SINGLE
ATTACKS OF THIS ENTIRE WAR.
AT LEAST 40 PEOPLE WERE KILLED
WHEN A RUSSIAN MISSILE JUST TAKE
A LOOK AT THIS VIDEO, IT JUST
OBLITERATED HUGE PORTIONS OF AN
APARTMENT COMPLEX IN DNIPRO.
AND DOZENS OF PEOPLE ARE STILL
MISSING RIGHT NOW.
FRED PLEITGEN JOINS US AT THIS
HOUR.
WHAT IS GOING ON THERE RIGHT
NOW?
>> Reporter: HI THERE, KATE.
AND YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, THE
MAGNITUDE OF DESTRUCTION IS
INCREDIBLE.
I'LL GET OUT OF THE WAY SO YOU
COULD SEE WHAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW WHICH IS FIRST OF ALL
THIS GAPING HOLE, A LARGE PART
OF THE BUILDING USED TO BE.
BUT YOU COULD SEE HOW THE RESCUE
AND RECOVERY EFFORTS AND THE
CLEAN-UP EFFORT ARE STILL GOING
ON.
AND OFFICIALLY THE UKRAINIANS
SAY THIS IS A SEARCH AND RESCUE
EFFORT BY THE CHANCES OF FINDING
ANYBODY ALIVE IN WHAT YOU SEE
THERE IN FRONT OF YOU, REALLY IS
DWINDLING AND GOING TOWARDS
ZERO.
AND THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WHO
WERE KILLED IN THIS INCIDENT,
THEY HAVE CONTINUED TO RISE
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE
DAY.
RIGHT NOW WE DO STAND AT 40
KILLED.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE COME OUT AND
CLAIMED THAT THEY WERE NOT
BEHIND THIS STRIKE.
THEY SAY THIS WAS A STRAY
UKRAINIAN ANTI-AIR MISSILE THAT
HIT THE BUILDING AND THE
UKRAINIANS NOT HAVING ANY OF
THAT.
THEY SAY THAT THEY TRACKED THE
MISSILE FIRED BY THE RUSSIANS
FROM THE SEE OF AZOF TO HERE
WHERE IT IMPACTED AND IT IS A
KH-22 CRUISE MISSILE WHICH IS A
MISSILE THAT IS NORMALLY USED,
THAT IS IT DESIGNED TO DESTROY
AIRCRAFT CARRIERS.
THAT IS WHAT THE MISSILE THAT
THEY SAY HIT THIS BUILDING AND
WHEN A MISSILE LIKE THAT HITS
THE BUILDING LIKE THIS, YOU HAVE
THE DESTRUCTION THAT YOU SEE
BEFORE YOUR VERY EYES RIGHT NOW.
AND I COULD TELL YOU BEING ON
THE GROUND HERE, SEEING SOME OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE FROM THIS
AREA, SEEING SOME OF THE
RELATIVES, THERE IS ABSOLUTE
GRIEF AND ANGER HERE ON THE
GROUND FROM A LOT OF PEOPLE.
OBVIOUSLY MANY PEOPLE CURSING
THE RUSSIANS AFTER THIS
INCIDENT.
BUT CERTAINLY THE PEOPLE THAT
WE'RE SPEAKING TO ALSO SAYING
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE BROUGHT
DOWN BY WHAT HAPPENED HERE JUST
A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO, KATE.
>> THE RESOLVE STILL.
TO CONTINUE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO WATCH AS THIS
IS STILL A SEARCH AND RESCUE
EFFORT.
JOINING ME NOW IS LIEUTENANT
GENERAL MART HERTLING.
WHAT DO YOU SEE IN THIS
DEVASTATING ATTACK ON THIS
APARTMENT COMPLEX.
>> WELL LET'S FIRST TALK ABOUT
WHETHER THIS IS A RUSSIAN
MISSILE OR AN AIR DEFENSE
MISSILE.
IT IS THE FORMER, NOT THE
LATTER.
IT DOESN'T TAKE AN EXPERT TO
DETERMINE THAT THAT WAS
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF POUNDS OF
EXPLOSIVES IN A MISSLE THAT
CONTRIBUTED TO THAT BUILDING
FALLING.
AND AN AIR DEFENSE MISSILE DOES
NOT HAVE THAT.
SO IT IS ANOTHER INSTANCE OF
RUSSIA JUST FLAT OUT LYING.
NOW, I WON'T GET TOO GEEKY ON
AIR.
BUT THIS IS AN ISSUE OF A
STRATEGY OF ATTRITION ON
RUSSIA'S APPROACH.
IN WARFARE THERE IS STRATEGIES
OF ATTRITION WHERE YOU TRY TO
EXHAUST THE ENEMY AND WEAR THEM
DOWN AND BRING DIFFERENT THINGS
TO BEAR.
ANNIHILATION IS WHERE YOU TRY
AND OUTMANEUVER THE ENEMY, GET
THEM IN A POSITION WHERE YOU
COULD ATTACK THEM AND FORCE A
DECISION ON THE PART OF OTHER
GOVERNMENT TO SURRENDER.
BUT THE DIFFERENCE HERE IS
RUSSIA IS USING A STRATEGY OF
ATTRITION NOT AGAINST THE
UKRAINE MILITARY FORCE, BUT
AGAINST THE CIVILIAN FORCE.
AND IN AN ATTEMPT TO MAKE
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HAVE A LACK
OF WILL TO CONTINUE THIS FIGHT.
IT IS NOT WORKING, AS YOU JUST
SAID.
THERE IS MORE RESILIENCE NOW IN
UKRAINE THAN THERE HAS EVER
BEEN.
BUT THIS IS GOING TO CONTINUE.
>> YOU KNOW, IT IS INTERESTING,
GENERAL, BECAUSE THE FORMER
DEFENSE SECRETARY MARK ESPER WAS
ON THIS MORNING AND HE SPOKE
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT,
WHAT THIS SAYS ABOUT THE WAR AND
TALKED ABOUT THE WAR THAT -- I
BELIEVE THE WORD THAT HE USED,
BEING IN A STALE MMATE RIGHT NO.
AND HOW DOES UKRAINE BREAK OUT
THIS, THIS STALEMATE MOMENT.
WHAT CAN BE DONE AND WHAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE?
>> WELL I DON'T AGREE WITH
SECRETARY ESPER ON THAT.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE IN A
STALEMATE.
THERE ARE STRUGGLES GO ON IN
KHERSON AND IN THE DONBAS AND IT
IS A DIFFERENCE IN APPROACH
BETWEEN RUSSIA TRYING TO EFFECT
THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE WHILE
UKRAINE'S ARMY IS TRYING TO
EFFECT THE RUSSIAN ARMY AND GET
THEM OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS A STRATEGY OF ATTRITION.
FORCED DECISIONS BECAUSE YOU ARE
DEFEATING THE SECURITY FORCE OF
THE ENEMY.
SO THIS IS CERTAINLY NOT A
STALEMATE.
BUT WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN, YOU
KNOW, UNFORTUNATELY, A COUPLE OF
THINGS.
RUSSIA HAS TO RUN OUT OF
AMMUNITION WHICH I DON'T SEE
HAPPENING ANY TIME SOON.
THERE ARE CERTAINLY INDICATORS
THAT THEY HAVE LESS AND LESS
BALLISTIC MISSILES TO FIRE.
BUT IN THIS CASE, I MEAN, AS AN
EXAMPLE, THIS WEEKEND THOSE
KH-22 MISSILES THAT FRED WAS
JUST TALKING ABOUT, INDICATORS
ARE THERE IS ABOUT 50 OF THEM AS
PART OF THEIR BLACK SEA FLEET
THAT RUSSIA CAN FIRE.
THEY ALLEGEDLY FIRED ABOUT 14
THIS WEEKEND.
SO YOU STILL HAVE ALMOST THREE
QUARTERS OF THE ONES LEFT ON
SHIPS AND SUBMARINES IN THE
BLACK SEA AS WELL AS COMING BY
AIR.
SO, IT IS GOING TO CONTINUE.
BUT WHAT HAS HAPPEN TO HAPPEN
WITH UKRAINE IS THEY HAVE TO GET
AN IMPROVEMENT IN THEIR MANEUVER
FORCE TO CONTINUE TO CONDUCT
ATTACKS AND OFFENSIVES AGAINST
THE RUSSIANS MILITARY AND
CONTINUE TO DRIVE THEM OUT OF
THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS WHAT YOU SEE.
IT IS SOMEWHAT OF A STALEMATE
BETWEEN TYPES OF STRATEGIES.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT UKRAINE WILL
HAVE THE POWER TO CONTINUE THEIR
COUNTER OFFENSES.
>> THANK YOU FOR COMING IN,
GENERAL.
GABRIELLE US IS THE FOREIGN
MINISTER OF LITHUANIA.
HE JOINS ME NOW FROM THE WORLD
ECONOMIC FORUM.
I WILL ASK YOU TO GIVE US A
SENSE OF WHAT IT IS THAT YOU
WILL BE ADDRESSING THE AUDIENCE
THERE WITH WHAT YOUR MESSAGE IS
LIKELY TO BE AT THIS STAGE.
DO YOU BELIEVE SOME COUNTRIES
ARE TRYING TO STALL SENDING
WEAPONS TO UKRAINE?
IF SO, WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I THINK THAT
WE CAN CLEARLY SEE THAT THE
EVENTS IN UKRAINE, THE MOST
HORRIBLE EVENTS MAKE US SEND
THE WEAPONS THAT UKRAINIANS
NEED.
AT FIRST IT WAS AN ATTACK ON
KYIV, THEN IT WAS 20 PUTIN.
THEN OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE THE
ATTACK ON DNIPRO.
NOW THE DEBATE ABOUT THE TANKS
IS FINALLY GETTING SOME FUEL.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS THE RIGHT
ATTITUDE, HONESTLY.
I DON'T THINK THAT UKRAINIAN
CIVILIANS SHOULD BE PAYING WITH
THEIR LIVES IN ORDER TO GET THE
WEAPONS THAT THEY NEED.
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE WAY MORE
SERIOUS ABOUT HOW DO WE SEE
THIS WAR ENDING.
IT HAS TO END IN UKRAINE, BY
UKRAINIANS WINNING THE
TERRITORY, SO THAT NOW THEY ARE
NOT UNDER RUSSIAN OCCUPATION.
FOR THAT, MOST OF ALL THEY NEED
WEAPONRY.
ALL KINDS OF WEAPONRY.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, IT IS TANKS,
MAIN BATTLE TANKS.
GERMANY HAS THEM, UNITED STATES
HAS THEM AND ALSO LONG-RANGE
ROCKETS THAT WILL BE USED IN
ORDER TO PUSH RUSSIAN TROOPS
OUT OUT OF THE OCCUPIED
TERRITORIES.
>> YOU TALKED TO ENOUGH OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES AROUND EUROPE TO
KNOW WHAT THE CURRENT THINKING
IS.
DO YOU BELIEVE WE ARE ENTERING
A NEW PHASE IN THIS WAR?
DO OTHERS IN EUROPE AGREE?
AND IF SO, DO YOU BELIEVE THE
UKRAINIANS WILL GET WHAT THEY
WANT AT THIS POINT?
I KNOW YOU ARE SUGGESTING THEY
SHOULD, BUT WHAT ARE THEY
LIKELY TO GET?
AND WHAT IS HOLDING OFF THE
DELIVERY OF FURTHER MILITARY
AID?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT BASICALLY
THE DISCUSSION IN THE WEST IS
STILL ABOUT THE END OF THE WAR
AND THERE ARE THOSE WHO BELIEVE
THAT MAYBE A FROZEN CONFLICT
WOULD BE SUITED BETTER, WHICH I
COMPLETELY DISAGREE WITH THAT
NOTION, BUT THIS NOTION, THIS
THINKING IS I THINK THE MAIN
OBSTACLE FOR SOME COUNTRIES TO
SEND THE WEAPONS THAT
UKRAINIANS NEED.
INDEED, IT TOOK A VERY LONG
TIME, ALMOST A YEAR NOW TO GET
TO THE POINT WHERE WE ACTUALLY
ARE DISCUSSING SENDING TANKS.
HONESTLY, I WOULD NOT BE
EXTREMELY SURPRISED IF THE
TANKER DEBATE WOULD BE
PRODUCTIVE IN THE SENSE THAT
THE UKRAINIANS WOULD GET THEIR
HANDS ON THE TANKS.
I THINK THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY COUNTRY THAT IS
SUPPORTING UKRAINE WOULD GET TO
THE POINT AND AGREE ON THE
FINAL POINTS TO HOW THIS WAR
SHOULD END.
WE ONLY TO AGREE ON THE FACT
THAT UKRAINE NEEDS TO WIN THE
WAR, NEEDS TO GET RUSSIA OUT OF
ITS TERRITORY IF WE WANT THE
EUROPEAN CONTINENT TO BE SAFE
AGAIN.
AND IF WE WANT THE GLOBAL
SECURITY ORDER TO GET BACK INTO
WHAT IT WAS BEFORE AND, FOR
THAT, RUSSIA NEEDS TO LOSE.
FOR THAT, WE HAVE TO IMAGINE
AND UNDERSTAND THAT UKRAINE IS
ACTUALLY STILL FIGHTING AGAINST
A SUPERIOR FORCE.
THEREFORE, THERE IS NO WAY WE
CAN LEAVE THEM WITH WHERE THEY
ARE NOW AND WITH THE WEAPONS
THAT THEY CURRENTLY HAVE.
>> THE POLISH PRIME MINISTER
TODAY CALLING ON THE GERMANS TO
DO MORE.
AND I'M QUOTING HERE, TO SUPPLY
ALL SORTS OF WEAPONS TO
UKRAINE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THE GERMANS
SHOULD BE DOING MORE?
>> HONESTLY, YES.
I CONCUR THAT THERE ARE
MACHINERY, THERE ARE WEAPONS
THAT INDUSTRIAL WESTERN POWERS,
SUCH AS GERMANY, FRANCE AND
OTHERS CAN STILL DELIVER TO
UKRAINE.
THERE'S ALSO A SECOND THING IN
THIS STORY.
IT'S THAT A LOT OF COUNTRIES
HAVE ALREADY PROCURED GERMAN
MADE TANKS.
AMONG THOSE IS FINLAND AND SOME
OTHER NORDIC COUNTRIES, SOUTH
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES.
THEY ARE WILLING TO SEND THE
TANKS TO UKRAINE.
SO FAR, THEY HAVE NOT GOTTEN A
GREENLIGHT FROM BERLIN.
I TRULY, TRULY HOPE THAT THIS
MIGHT CHANGE AS WELL.
THAT WOULD PUT THE PRESSURE ON
GERMANY ITSELF, MEANING THAT
MAYBE THEY CANNOT SEND ALL THE
TANKS THAT UKRAINE NEEDS
CURRENTLY, BUT WITH PARTNERS
THAT HAVE GERMAN TANKS, IT
WOULD BE A SUBSTANTIAL HELP TO
UKRAINE.